So now let's get back to our retina.
So here we are.
So we, we've sort of talked, you know,
very briefly about the photo detectors.
Now we're going to talk
about the ganglion cells.
One of the things about the ganglion
cells is that they take
information from these things called
these horizontal and bipolar cells and
the horizontal cells just as you might
think they take information across
a local area and bring them
together to the ganglion cells.
So you might ask why would you do that.
>> Why would you do that?
>> Thank you, Megan.
Okay.
There are a lot of reasons.
One of which has to do
with dynamic range.
In fact, you know what,
let's go to this picture first, and
then we'll go to the numbers.
So here's a series of photographs
where you adjust the amount of light
coming into the image from a thousandth
of a second to a quarter of a second.
You see here there's an outdoor
part of the scene right there.
So a thousandth of a second isn't enough
when you open it up a little bit more it
gets a little bit easier
to see these things.
And then as I let in enough light that
I can see the interior really well
this outdoor thing is totally blown out.
And yet, if you were to stand there,
what you would see is something
that looks like this.
You'd have no problem seeing
the indoor stuff and outdoor stuff.
It might be a little bit harder to see,
but not anything like the camera and
that's because your system deals with
dynamic range so much more effectively.
Okay.
Here's another example of photographing
a high dynamic range scene.
Right, so, if you wanted to see
the stained glass really well you'd
have to miss the rest of
the inside of the church.
If you want to see the rest
of the inside of the church
these things get blown out.
But you would have no
problem seeing this.
You would see that beautiful stained
glass, and you would see the church.
You now know that there
are a couple of photography methods
called high dynamic range, so you have
a high dynamic range on your iPhone, or
your little phone, or whatever, or
in Photoshop, something like that.
That's a way of blending together
a series of pictures to automatically
select which regions from which
image should be selected,
or, or how much you dial up or
dial down each region of, of the image
in order to composite the whole thing
into a high dynamic range image.